kind to join us
um Maggie I want to start with you first
because you are a paid up party member
of the conservative party aren't you
absolutely
um with a very conservative name Maggie
of course
um how are you feeling about what's
transpired over the last week and
finally the knowledge that we have Rishi
sunak as prime minister I was very very
disappointed
about Liz truss and very worried
actually unsettled
but when I heard Rishi speak he was
standing at the podium
and I just I just relax completely and I
thought I trust this guy
he's down to earth
he's empathetic he he really does
understand what's going on and I think
he's going to be great for this country
and I'm absolutely confident that he
will sort it do I sense that you perhaps
felt that that Liz trust wasn't right
for the country then
I commend her enthusiasm I think her
heart was in the right place but
unfortunately
things went awry and I think too quickly
too soon it wasn't measured with Rishi I
feel he's stable he's 100 reliable
and I trust him and that was an instant
feeling just watching him in action and
hearing his words so that's the view
from the true blue to those of you who
are not so died in the wool Dennis for
example what what are your thoughts at
the moment about how you're feeling I
actually Echo a lot not the Maggie said
I feel that the turmoil chaos whatever
you'd like to call it over the past
six months or whatever has been
absolutely horrendous for the country
and from a personal perspective myself
doesn't affect so much but I've got
children I've got grandchildren and
they've got mortgages and the
unstability of the market is is a big
concern and therefore I think Rishi
coming in who is really financially
astute is a safe Pair of Hands and
hopefully over the next two years to up
to the next election he can steady the
ship and our children and grandchildren
can have a bit more stability so they
can plan their future
um Jim finally turning to you I mean
your thoughts and the other thing I want
to throw into the mix is do any of you
think that you know rather than the
third prime minister in you know as many
months practically we should be thinking
about a general election
well no I think
um
Richie Richie coming in to I I think he
should have been there before lose trust
anyway
it was my fault I think first and
foremost he's a businessman
and I think really the country needs a
businessman to run it
we are in Dire Straits really the
pandemic you know and the money that's
been thrown
at the pandemic it needs again we keep
saying a steady Pair of Hands but
basically we do need
a a complete businessman to to to run
this country spoken like a true
businessman because you are indeed a
businessman I am yeah Mitchell's carpets
that's right but
um you know and I feel that you know
I've got nothing against Liz trust I've
got nothing against a woman prime
minister in general because I think
Maggie Thatcher was one of the best best
business women businessman in in the you
know in history but
um you know Liz trust just wasn't up to
the job and she tried to do far too much
far too soon and it just obviously just
went just threw back in her face you
know well look we'll get your reactions
to Richie sunax first prime minister's
questions afterwards but for now I'm
going to thank our expert panel and
throw back to you in the studio and
you'll come and join us I think in
another half an hour's time or so once
he's stepped off his feet in the Commons
yeah Matthew we will do we'll get voters
reaction to What Rishi seen at Castle to
say in his first pmqs in the Commons
it's starting around 10 minutes time
we're going to bring in some members of
parliament now to get their thoughts on
what the new PM needs to do to make his
Mark at midday we're joined now from
Central London by the conservative MP
Nikki Aitkin and with me here in the
studio labors Ian Murray who is the
shadow Secretary of State for Scotland
and the Scottish parties MP for Glasgow
East David Linden uh good to see you all
thank you so much for joining us and
Nikki I'll come to you first in the big
screen what's that big thing you want to
hear from Rishi soon actually what you
think he's got to do to hit the ground
running
what else exactly what he did yesterday
to provide
um Parliament but more importantly the
country with the reassurance that he
knows the huge economic crisis that we
are in and that he has the answers with
his cabinet to ensure that we do get out
of this crisis and
um make sure that we can continue then
to grow the economy and to safeguard our
Public Services
and you mentioned you know him providing
answers not sure how many we're going to
get that are concrete for the public
until the 17th of November uh Ian Murray
that fiscal statement on Halloween has
now been upgraded to a full Autumn
statement on the 17th of November that's
another
um two and a half weeks for the public
to wait the markets haven't reacted
there doesn't seem to be any panic at
the moment we're keeping an eye on them
what's your reaction to this further
delay well the government have refused
to publish any official statistics from
the office for Budget responsibility or
if you get an Autumn statement or a
budget you would normally get a red book
that has all the figures in there and
until we get that nobody can really
assess the real chaos and damage the
economy that this government has caused
and I think their figures are pretty
dire which is why it's probably been
delayed and what I want to hear from
Russia prime minister's questions an
explanation about his strategy which is
what he said in the summer about taking
money from other private areas and
putting it into the conservative Shire
areas I want to an apology for of what's
been done to the economy over the last
few years this isn't just to do with
Ukraine inflation was happening when he
was chancelled and of course the former
prime minister called it piffpaff when
he was asked if he had concerns about
inflation so an apology would be a good
start I think for all the people across
the country that are struggling to pay
their mortgages struggling to pay their
energy bills and look at the cost of
living and wonder how they're going to
get through the winter
David what would you like to hear from
the new prime minister he's talked a lot
about compassion he's also talked a lot
about difficult decisions ahead and I
was just talking to a conservative
members panel before
and we were discussing how pragmatism
and compassion are a Ready Mix at the
moment
well I mean I think it's bizarre to a
little bit compassion when he's just
appointed Home Secretary who had to
resign six days ago for a major security
breach and who is intent on pursuing a
plan to deport vulnerable refugees to
Rwanda and what I want to hear from
Russia sunak fundamentally is that he's
going to stand up and so he's off to the
Palace to dissolve parliament and call a
general election this is the second
conservative prime minister we've had in
seven weeks another 40 prime minister
that Scotland didn't vote for he has no
Democratic legitimacy the best thing
that he can do now is call a general
election and allow people to have their
C because it's quite clear to me that
after 12 years of Tory austerity that
has caused something in excess of 335
000 deaths excess deaths according to
the Glasgow Center for population Health
that this austerity in government is is
not something that people in Scotland
want we've not voted majority
conservatives since the 1950s Russia
sunak has no mandate in Scotland and he
must call a general election David I
don't think you're going to get the
answer you want when it comes to a
general election
yeah but we might though get some
answers on the situation regarding
swella Braven and reappointed as Home
Secretary as you pointed out after
breaching the ministerial code
um and resigning that was just six seven
days ago now and Nikki your thoughts on
that because
it was described as unfortunate by a
guest earlier but Rishi sudak will have
seen this controversy coming and many
people will be thinking what's gone on
behind the scenes for him to reappoint
her do you think he'll shed any light on
that today an urgent question is being
asked by labor after PM Keys
oh Nicky apologies we can't hear you or
just fade up your microphone
no I think he's Aaron Nikki
okay the Prime Minister the Prime
Minister was very clear yesterday in his
speech that he is determined to to unite
this this conservative party and ensure
that his cabinet uh it represents the
whole of the party and that's what he's
done and Sue Ella made a mistake she
admitted it last week she resigned and
now she's back because the Prime
Minister has full faith in her and let's
see uh know how she responds as Home
Secretary she was doing you know a
sterling job and I'm sure she will
continue to do so now with her brilliant
team it's such a controversial
appointment though could this be the
prime minister's first u-turn
look the Prime Minister was very clear
we are a very broad Church in the
conservative party and if we are going
to unite and if we are going to do what
we have to do to ensure that this
country comes out of this economic
crisis we have to have all the talents
from across the party and Sue Ella was a
leadership
and the smps MP for Glasgow East is
shaking his head in incredulillah
a breadth of Talent Plus the story party
this is a grubby deal that's been done
in Westminster on Sunday night for a
celebrity women to come out and support
Rishi soon act and he's had to reward us
is that not just politics though because
British see that has to unite the
conservative party and to unite the
conservative party he needs people on
his side to get legislation through
Parliament these deals are always done
regardless of what at all I mean part of
the problem he does what we're seeing is
a recycling of fields former ministers
and we've seen Russia tonight you've got
a fine Jordan Park ticket he broke the
rules
who obviously had to resign as a result
of a security Bridge she is the Home
Center in charge of security and six
days later she's back in charge of that
you didn't put an arsonist in charge of
putting out a fire and that's exactly
what we're seeing machine do you think
what you've seen today on every single
political program and news program this
morning is conservative cabinet members
and indeed conservative MPS defending
the indefensible again I mean they're
well practiced at it they've been doing
it for three years now and now they're
defending this decision and it is it
isn't a reshuffle it's a recycling it's
the same old people in the same old jobs
for the same old Tire conservative party
and really we need an election to clear
all of this out and start again a lot of
these points are going to come out in
Keys which is getting underway in a
couple of minutes time our political
editor Beth Rigby has joined us in the
studios we build up to that uh there we
go a Full House of Commons now or a few
spaces earlier but we're just a couple
of minutes away Beth what do you think
we're going to see from Rishi sunak
he's going to try to continue what he's
already begun which is this is a new era
this is a new uh way of doing business
and it will be all about trying to be
strong and stable to use one of those
terms from Theresa May after the
absolute chaos we've seen in recent
weeks I think from sarcastarma it would
be quite simple he would be saying you
have not got legitimacy you cannot
change the Prime Minister twice in seven
weeks without asking the public what
they think about it I imagine Mr sunat
will say I'm sticking to the 2019
Manifesto and you heard him on the
streets at Downing Street when he said
it wasn't one person's Manifesto it was
the conservative party I.E saying this
is not Boris Johnson's mandate it is
also mine as well and I will stick to
that agenda and not stray from it so
those might be the batteries I think the
swella bravaman issue is a real issue
and I think it will come up I've already
got a source from the home office saying
that people are livid that she has been
reappointing wanted given that she was
sacked just six days ago for a security
breach in which she broke at the
ministerial code now even one past an
inside number 10 told me last night they
thought it was a mistake to reappoint
her why did Rishi sunak do it I think
there was a number of issues one she is
a flag bearer on the right of the party
he probably wanted to bind her into the
immigration issue which is so vexing for
that particular wing of the party and
also keep her close and keep her in line
with him and his cabinet but labor have
asked for an urgent question about the
reappointment after prime minister's
questions they've also written to the
cabinet secretary saying that they want
an investigation one source and I
haven't confirmed this has told me that
Simon case advised against that I don't
know if that's correct I need to check
that with down the street but it gives
you a sense of some of the turmoil
behind the scenes around this decision
and you can see that the opposition
parties are using this to attack Rishi
sunak pretty fiercely uh just 24 hours
or less than that into the job
well we've got around 10 seconds until
midday and the start of pmqs less than
that it is in fact midday we are
expecting Rishi Cena to stand up in a
few minutes time to start answering
those questions or a wide shot my eyes
aren't too good but I think it's Kevin
talking there at the moment um this
delayed fiscal statement now a full-on
Autumn uh statement on the 17th of
November Beth that will come up as well
yes and that decision was taken because
uh Russia sunak and his Chancellor now
think because the markets have become
Karma guilt yields have fallen that's
the cost of government debt is falling
uh the uh interest rate expectations are
also falling so they think they've got a
bit more maneuverability remember
quasiquartung the former Chancellor
actually initially put this statement at
November 23rd he then had to bring It
Forward because of Market Panic so it's
really going back to giving to where it
once was more or less and given uh Rishi
sunak a little bit more time just
wondering if he came in there as Jay
because there was a bit of a cheer I
think he might be you couldn't quite see
yeah
but I'm sure that that will also come up
at the moment the cost of living crisis
at the economic chaos inflicted by Liz
truss on the country
prime minister
[Applause]
Mr Speaker they could have just said
don't damage the furniture cheering by
all means well don't damage come on
Mr Speaker this morning I had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today
[Applause]
I'd like to congratulate the Prime
Minister on his uh new post and indeed
as being the first prime minister of a
South Asian Heritage
will be a cause of great pride among
many of my constituents I also have some
pride in welcome welcoming a fellow
Saints Southampton supporter into number
10.
um during his during his prime
ministerial campaigns the last Prime
ministerial campaign he'd ran
he he pledge to prohibit any development
of onshore wind which is now
the cheapest form of power available to
us in the country now he is prime
minister will he change his mind on that
point
well Mr Speaker I Thank The Honorable
gentleman for his uh kind words and look
forward to seeing him at St Mary's
although I know my my friend the uh the
leader of the House may have something
to say about our love of uh of saints
look when it comes to energy policy I
stick by what we said in our Manifesto
Mr Speaker the important thing is though
to focus on our long-term energy
security that means more Renewables more
offshore wind and indeed more nuclear
that's what this government will deliver
[Applause]
I'm surprised Mr Speaker to be asking
the question and I know your shops Mr
Speaker too because I know that you like
many people thought I would have already
been offered a ministerial
[Applause]
let me tell you I didn't told my breath
the lips
go go figure as Joe Biden might say yeah
[Music]
can I can I can I congratulate can I
congratulate my right honorable friend
on becoming prime minister
it's absolutely the right person for the
job and I wish him every success in post
and as he knows he's got my full support
he's
[Applause]
his two immediate predecessors made
leveling up a key part of their agenda
would he reaffirm his commitment to
leveling up and start as a means to go
on by approving the leveling up fund bid
for Bingley in my Constitution
[Applause]
wow I'm uh I'm I'm great I'm grateful to
my uh honorable friend uh for his his
warm remarks I can't confirm he must be
the only person Mr Speaker who texted me
to say that he did not want a job
uh but I can give him my cast iron
commitment to leveling up particularly
in Yorkshire which he and I share uh
obviously he'll he'll know I can't
comment on individual bids but by the
end of the year an announcement is
expected on the success and I wish him
every luck with that let's jump to the
leader of the opposition Kia stama
thank you Mr Speaker and may I welcome
the Prime Minister the first British
Asian prime minister is a significant
moment in our national story and it's a
reminder that for all the challenges we
face as a country Britain is a place
where people of all Races and all
beliefs can fulfill their dreams
that's not true in every country and
many didn't and many didn't think that
they would live to see the day when it
would be true here it's part of what
makes us all so proud to be British
was his Home Secretary right to resign
last week for a breach of security
[Music]
for his kind and indeed generous uh
welcome to the dispatch box I look
forward to Primus question time with him
and I know that we will have no doubt
robust exchanges but I hope that they
can also be serious and grown up so I
look forward to it well he he asked
about the hometown the Home Secretary
made an error of judgment but she
recognized that she raised the matter
and she accepted her mistake and that's
why that's why I was delighted to
welcome back into a United cabinet that
brings experience foreign Ty to the
heart of government and let me tell you
Mr Speaker what the Home Secretary will
be focused on she'll be focused on
cracking down on criminals
offending our borders
while the party opposite remains soft on
crime and in favor of unlimited
immigration
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker yesterday the Prime Minister
stood on the steps of Downing Street and
promised Integrity professionalism and
accountability but then with his first
act he appointed a Home Secretary who
was sacked by his predecessor a week ago
for deliberately pinging around
sensitive home office documents from her
personal account
um far from soft on time I ran the crown
prosecution service for five years
[Applause]
the take on terrorists and serious
organized crime and I know firsthand how
important it is that we have a Home
Secretary whose integrity and
professionalism are Beyond question
so have officials raised concerns about
his decision to appoint her
[Music]
Mr Mr Speaker I just addressed the issue
with the Home Secretary but but he uh he
talked about fighting crime I would hope
[Applause]
the speaker I would hope that he would
welcome I would hope I would hope that
as we look forward he would welcome the
news today that there are over 15 000
new police officers
[Music]
and the Home Secretary will be
supporting them to tackle burglaries
well the party opposite the party offers
it will be backing The Lunatic
protesting Fringe that are stopping
through working
working well Mr Speaker I listened
carefully that was clearly not to know
we can all see what's happened here he's
so weak he's done a grubby deal trading
National Security because he was scared
to lose another leadership election
there's a new Tory at the top but as
always with them party first country
second
yesterday yesterday on the steps of
Downing Street he also admitted what the
whole country knows the Tories have
crashed the economy and now somebody has
to pay for their mess I say it shouldn't
be working people who've been hammered
Time and Again by this lot but those
with the broadest shoulders must Step Up
does he agree
well Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman
talked about party first and Country
second perhaps he could explain to us
why it was a few years ago he was
supporting the member for Islington
North
let's go
Mr Speaker
my record is clear when times are
difficult in this country I will always
protect the most vulnerable that is
[Applause]
we will do that again
Mr Speaker he says he'll protect the
most vulnerable Let's test that the
government currently allows very rich
people to live here but register abroad
for tax purposes I don't need to explain
to the Prime Minister how non-dom status
Works he already knows all about that
it cost the treasury 3.2 billion pounds
every year
why doesn't he put his mouth where's
money where his mouth is and get rid of
it
well Mr Speaker I have belongs we will
have to take difficult decisions to
restore economic stability and
confidence and my honorable friend the
chancellor will set that out at an
Autumn statement in just a few weeks but
what I can say as we did during covid we
will always protect the most vulnerable
we will do this and a fair way but what
I can say I am glad Mr Speaker that the
party opposite honorable gentleman has
finally realized that spending does need
to be paid for
it is a novel concept for the party
opposite this government is going to
restore economic stability and we will
do it in a fair and compassionate way
[Applause]
I know it's been away for a few weeks
but you should have listened what's been
going on the last two
but anyway I I I have to say I'm
surprised he's still defending non-dom
status
he pretends he's on the side of working
people
but in private he says something very
different
over the summer he was secretly recorded
at a garden party in Tunbridge Wells
and he personally moved money away from
deprived areas to wealthy places instead
rather than apologize or pretend that he
meant something else why doesn't he now
do the right thing and undo the changes
that he made to those funding formulas
[Applause]
I know I I know the right I know the
right honorable gentleman rarely Leaves
North London
but if he does but if if he does he will
know that there are deprived areas in
our rural communities
and across the South and this government
will relentlessly support them because
we are a government that will deliver
for people across the United Kingdom Mr
Mr Speaker he APS in the last few weeks
I am the first to admit that mistakes
were made and that's the reason I am
standing here but that but that is the
difference between him and me this
summer I was talking I was being honest
about the difficulties that we were
facing but when he ran for leader when
he ran for leader he promised his party
he would borrow billions and billions of
pounds I told the truth for the good of
the country he told his party what it
wanted to hear leadership is not selling
fairy tales it is confronting challenges
and that is the leadership the British
people will get from this government
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
I think everyone should watch the video
and make their own minds up in public he
claims he wants to level up the north
but then he boasts about trying to
funnel vital investment away from
deprived areas he says one thing and
does another well that's shouting
they're not my words they're not my
words
they're the words of the former chair of
the Tory party sat yesterday for telling
the truth about the Prime Minister even
his own side no he's not on the side of
working people that's why the only time
he ran in a competitive election he got
trounced by the former prime minister
who herself got beaten by a lettuce
so why doesn't he put it to the test let
working people have their say and call a
general election
thank you
[Applause]
well it'll take a long time to get
through this paper if we carry on like
those prime minister
Mr Speaker he talks about mandates about
votes about elections it's a bit Rich
coming from the person who tried to
overturn the biggest Democratic vote
our mandate is based on a Manifesto that
we were elected on to remind him an
election that we won and they lost
a mandate that says we want a stronger
NHS better schools safer streets control
of our borders and leveling up that is
the Mandate that I and this government
will deliver for the British people
[Applause]
and there's not even answer a question
you want more come on Heather thank you
very much Mr Speaker
um I'd like to congratulate our new my
right number of friends and new prime
minister and also to thank our previous
prime minister for the straightforward
way she has handled her resignation and
I wish her and her family well for the
future
would my right honor a friend please use
this his first appearance of the
dispatch box to make it clear to the
British medical Council and the British
Dental Association that as well as
training more more training spaces
opening up that they must allow new
doctors and dentists to work in the UK
so that the good people of South
Derbyshire can get treatment on the NHS
well I thank I thank my honorable friend
for her question she's absolutely right
I'm pleased that there are three and a
half thousand more doctors and over nine
thousand more nurses working this year
than last but she's right and we are
working to simplify the registration for
dentists in particular that are not
trained here to practice here and that's
how we'll help deliver a long-term
Workforce plan for the NHS and ensure
everyone can get the care they need
let's come to the leader of the SMP Ian
Blackfoot
thank you Mr Speaker tonight I
congratulate the new prime minister on
becoming the first British Asians to
hold the office the significance and the
symbolism of this achievement is to be
warmly welcomed by everyone Mr Speaker
yesterday on the steps of Downing Street
the new prime minister promised to bring
an I quote compassion to the challenges
that we face today so on his first full
day in the job let's put that to the
test a winter of uncertainty is coming
and next April we'll see a cliff Edge
moment Millions
as the energy price guarantee is cut off
while households are hit by austerity
2.0 and their real terms cut to Social
Security benefits that many rely on to
survive if people are actually to trust
the new prime minister's words about
compassion will he today reassure people
and guarantee that benefits will rise in
line with inflation in his upcoming
budget
on this vehicle I thank the Ronald for
his uh again kind remarks and what I can
tell him is my record on this is clear
through the difficult times that we
faced in this country through covid I
always acted in a way to protect the
most vulnerable that's because it is the
right thing to do and those are the
values of our compassionate party and I
can absolutely reassure him and give him
that commitment that we will continue to
act like that in the weeks ahead
well Mr Speaker let's test that because
as Chancellor the Prime Minister slashed
Universal Credit and presided over the
worst
[Applause]
side I might remind them that Universal
Credit was cut by 20 pounds a week and
presided over the worst levels of
poverty in Northwest Europe so I hope
that he has learned from his mistakes
and guarantees that benefits will rise
in line with inflation
speaking of mistakes
yesterday the Prime Minister appointed a
Home Secretary who was forced to resign
only last week for breaching the
ministerial codes and who boasted
boasted that she dreamed of sending
vulnerable Asylum Seekers to Rwanda we
all know why he appointed her a sleazy
backroom deal to shore up his own
position far from being a fresh start
this is a return to the sleaze and
Scandal and ghosts of cabinets first the
Prime Minister promised the government
with integrity and humility so if he has
amounts of either will he admit his
mistake and sacked the Home Secretary
without the delay
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I was pleased to actually
have a call last night with the first
minister of Scotland it was important
that I spoke to her on my first day in
office because I wanted to express my
desire to work constructively with the
Scottish government so that we can work
together to deliver for the people of
Scotland and that is what I plan to do
and indeed I hope crime is one of the
things that we can collaborate on
because he will know that violent crime
is rising in Scotland and police numbers
are falling whereas here we are
increasing police numbers Mr Speaker but
I look forward I look forward to working
with the Scottish government on our
shared challenges because I believe in a
strong United Kingdom
Andrew Marissa Mr Speaker what a
pleasure it was to welcome the prime
minister to my constituency in the
summer he will know one of the burning
issues in my constituency is the
proposed waste incinerator at West Green
with the government rightly reviewing
its air quality targets can I ask my
right honorable friend to Signal his
intent to continue promoting Public
Health Net Zero and the environment by
placing a moratorium on any more
unwanted unnecessary toxic waste buds
prime minister I can tell my honorable
friend I know he's been a vociferous
campaign on this issue as I as I learned
over the summer he'll know that local
authorities determine these issues but
also to reassure them that all large
incinerators in England must comply with
strict emission limits and only receive
permits If plants don't cause any damage
to human health and hopefully that is
reassuring for him Caroline Lucas thank
you very much uh Mr Speaker the prime
minister's Reckless predecessor took a
wrecking ball to Nature prompting
millions of members of the rspb The
National Trust and the wildlife trust to
rise up in opposition yesterday he
promised to fix her mistakes as well as
to uphold the party's 2019 Manifesto so
if he is a man of his word will he start
by reversing the green light she gave to
fracking since it's categorically not
been shown to be safe and instead
maintain the moratorium that was pledged
in that very moral talk in that very
Manifesto that he has promised to uphold
well I've already said I stand by the
manifesto on that but what I would say
is that I'm proud that this government
has passed the landmark environment Act
more Precision for the national
environment than we've ever had with a
clear plan to deliver and I can give the
honorable lady my commitment that we
will deliver on all those Ambitions we
will deliver on what we said at cop
because we care deeply about passing our
children an environment in better State
than we found in ourselves
thank you Mr Speaker I too would like to
welcome the prime minister to his place
farmers in my constituency of cluid
South are delighted that after 20 years
they are once more able to sell Welsh
lamb to the U.S market
would the Prime Minister comment on the
size and Prospects of this market for
our world-beating Welsh lamb
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I congratulate my uh my
colleague on the Fantastic achievement I
could tell him that market is worth I
think something like almost 40 million
pounds over the first few years enormous
boost uh for our land Farmers I would
just encourage the 300 million U.S
consumers to give Yorkshire Swale Dale a
lamb and looking as uh as well but I
know he and I if we disagree on that are
united on the fact that we will
unequivocally back British farming and
British Farmers
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker this is
certainly a topsy-turvy Tory government
a few days ago I was going to put my
question to the former prime minister
but my inbox has been full of emails
from constituents of nursemies writing
to me about their desperate situation of
their wages simply not going far enough
I'm also receiving emails about rents
going up Energy prices going up
mortgages going up and of course the
cost of living is already out this week
my constituents are writing to me
demanding a general election and I
absolutely agree with them so can the
prime Minister tell me and my
constituents when there will be a
general election
[Applause]
everybody address that but I would say
as I said in the summer I
summer I said inflation is indeed the
enemy it makes everyone poorer it in
Road savings and that's why it will be a
priority of our government to grip and
reduce inflation and provide support to
those who need it as we do in Bethlehem
thank you Mr Speaker this Autumn I'm
launching my campaign to extend the
Chilton's area of natural beauty across
thousands of Acres of Scenic Beauty
chalk streams and valuable habitats that
happen to surround the wonderful town of
Hitchin in my constituency would the
Prime Minister join me in celebrating
areas protected by aonb status and
indeed support my campaign to
potentially extend them in rural
Hertfordshire yeah well I thank my
honorable friend because I know this is
a matter of great importance for him and
his constituents and he's right to
highlight the benefit that Natural Parks
and aombs can bring to our lives and our
well-being I understand actually that
Natural England is considering an
extension of the children's area of
outstanding natural beauty and I know
honorable friend will be very obviously
taking up his campaign with them it's
your burger thank you thank you Mr
Speaker and I welcome the prime minister
to his place
a nurse would have to work over 20 000
years in order to match the vast wealth
of this prime minister the prime
minister
[Music]
too well that the super rich could
easily afford to pay more in taxes so
rather than an ounce a new wave of
cooked and austerity wouldn't it be
fairer for the prime minister to
introduce wealth taxes on the very
richest in our society
well Mr Speaker we will always support
our hard-working nurses and that's why
as Chancellor we reintroduce the nurse's
bursary and provided more training and
introduced actually very strong pain
creases but as I committed to previously
as we approached the difficult decisions
that confront us we will do so in a way
that is fair and is compassionate
because those are our values and that's
what we will deliver
it
thank you Mr Speaker I welcome my right
honor of friends determination to be
straight with people about the
challenges we face as a country
last week the Care Quality Commission
State of care report the state of care
in England showed our health system in
gridlock and I hear the same from my
constituents struggling to see a GP all
waiting for treatment so can I urge him
to make unblocking the NHS a priority
for him and his health secretary
so well my my honorable friend knows
this subject obviously very well from
her own experience and I thank her for
the work she did previously in the
department she's absolutely right about
the challenge that confronts us it's why
we've put billions of pounds into
busting the backlogs and the elective
Recovery Fund and are delivering funding
and something to do that but I look
forward to working with her to deliver
what we said in our Manifesto and that
is a fast stronger NHS Lynn Smith
thank you Mr Speaker right at my own
congratulations to the Prime Minister on
his appointment so we might not agree on
everything but I think we can all agree
a more diverse politics can only be to
the good now we in these benches believe
that Scotland's best future is
independence in Europe
[Applause]
Mr Speaker I really would urge the
members opposites to show a little more
respect
because it's not just us it's not just
us it's not just the SNP and I will not
be shouted down it's not just the SNP
and the last opinion Paul 72 percent of
the people of Scotland what bark into
the European Union
so if the prime ministers to maintain
any credibility in the eyes of the
people of Scotland how long does he
think he can deny Scotland's democracy
Mr Mr Speaker I thank uh general for his
kind words I mean he talked he talked
about respect I would gently urge him to
respect the result of the referendum
there was was we whilst we will whilst
we will disagree on that issue I can
tell him that I do remain committed to
working constructively in partnership
with a Scottish government to deliver
for the people of Scotland
thank you Mr Speaker last week I visited
worried year three and six pupils to
hear their suggestions to tackle Road
Safety following a number of serious
Road accidents outside boothroid Academy
in dewsbury they suggest that the
council should do more to help that
their parents should walk them to school
to reduce traffic and that commuter
should slow down would my right on a
friend agree with me and with them that
we all have a part to play in ensuring
Road Safety outside our schools
can I can I say to my honorable friend I
think it's fantastic that he's engaging
with his younger constituents at
boothroid Academy on such an important
issue and I know they will welcome his
commitment to supporting them and I
agree with him there are various things
we can do there's an updated Highway
code which strengthens pedestrian access
local authorities can introduce lower
speed limits and we're increasing the
number of school streets which restrict
motorized traffic at busy times and I
look forward to hearing progress on this
issue from him Stephen kinnick
thank you Mr Speaker yesterday the Prime
Minister stood on the steps of Downing
Street and said that he wanted to
restore trust yet in the past 24 hours
we've seen that he's prepared to
shamelessly swap red boxes for political
support and they're a real serious
consequences to all this horse trading
so I'd like him to be clear on this
point did he seek or receive any advice
on security concerns about the right
honorable member for South Staffordshire
before his appointment to the government
yesterday given that he was sacked in
2019 for leaking sensitive information
relating to our national security
Mr Speaker he's talking he's talking
about events that happened at four years
ago and he's talking but he's talking
he's talking he's right that he raised
he right that he raised the topic of
National Security because members
members opposite four years ago were
busily supporting the member for
Islington North
who wanted to abolish the nuclear
deterrent who wanted to leave NATO and
who wanted to scrap our Armed Forces we
won't take any lectures on National
Security Mr Speaker
thank you Mr Speaker I sincerely
congratulate my right honorable friend
and wish him every success
yeah over three years ago my constituent
Harry Dunn was killed in a tragic Road
accident and I'd like to ask my right
honorable friend to join me in
congratulating Harry Dunn's family for
the incredible campaign they've run for
over three years with huge support from
all colleagues across the house on
finally achieving Justice for Harry
thanks well I I pay tribute to my
honorable friend for her role and indeed
the former foreign secretary as well and
indeed colleagues from all over the
house for the part they've played and
bringing about this outcome my thoughts
are obviously with the family and I
joined in her sentiments that this is
very welcome Daisy Cooper thank you Mr
Speaker West Hertfordshire Hospital
trust in my area is still still hoping
to receive funds from the new hospitals
program the same program that is
supposed to deliver the government's
so-called 40 new hospitals there's been
a lot of speculation that the new prime
minister and his Chancellor might seek
to cut infrastructure projects so can
the Prime Minister confirm to me that my
local hospital trust as well as all of
the other local hospital trusts that are
set to benefit from new hospitals
program will in fact get that money yes
or no well Mr Speaker the chancellor
will set out our plans in the Autumn
statement shortly but this is the
government that put in place plans which
will remain to significantly increase
capital expenditure and even though
difficult decisions do need to be made I
think the country can rest assured that
we will continue to invest in our future
productivity and indeed invest in our
Public Services like the NHS
uh Mr Speaker
[Applause]
in my oldest brown Hills constituency
were at risk of 8 000 new homes being
dumped in the constituency will my right
honorable friend use the opportunity of
this prime minister's question to
reaffirm the government's commitment to
the to protecting the green belt and to
adopting a really rigorous Brownfield
first policy
well can I uh can I say thank you to my
vulnerable friend for her question uh
and I did I can give her that Assurance
she's absolutely right we must protect
our green belt and we are adopting a
Brownfield first strategy I'm pleased we
had a record number of new homes built
in the last year but it's important that
we build those homes in the right places
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker whilst welcoming
the new prime minister to his place we
remember that law breaking was the order
of the day in Downing street during the
pandemic we will never forget that this
current prime minister was fined by the
police for attending a birthday party
hosted by his next door neighbor as both
a witness and a participant of that law
breaking if the Privileges committee
investigation into the former prime
minister calls him to give evidence will
he fully cooperate yes
stuff Mr Speaker of course and I
addressed these matters earlier this
year
Mr Speaker you will know that I fought
hard to bring back Boris in 97 I
campaigned for Kenneth Clark
and then for Michael Portillo
so I can't always get it right
but you know I do know about the West
Midlands I know that the West Midlands
mayor very much welcomes the
reappointment of the leveling up
secretary and that he looked forward to
working with our new prime minister so
may I just ask him what is his vision
for leveling up
well I understand I think I thank my
honorable friend for their question and
and what I can say is our desire is to
ensure that people wherever they live in
our fantastic country have enormous
pride in the place they call home and
every opportunity to succeed and you
know what it is the Fantastic mayor Andy
Street who is delivering that for his
constituents in the West Midlands
questions
well that brings to a close at Rishi
tunak's first prime minister's questions
as the country's new prime minister and
political editor Beth Rigby was watching
uh proceedings with me here in the
studio Beth your overall impression
My overall impression is that both men
brought their a game if you like Rishi
sunak who was looking quite somber and
serious in the street yesterday when he
made his fast address as prime minister
was seemed very upbeat very combative
very confident at the dispatch box there
and uh Kia's farmer came in with some
pretty devastating questions and also
some pretty uh cruel put Downs actually
in order to try and get Rishi sunak on
his heels and I thought both men
actually gave a strong performances for
the conservative back benches to see Mr
sunac kind of approach and and really
attack prime minister's questions in the
way that at times Boris Johnson in the
past did as well would have been a
relief to them after some pretty
difficult performances for Liz truss she
only did three remember
but in terms of the substance of that
there were two themes that came out for
all three themes that came out I think
for kierstama the fast forwards on
policy that the appointment
reappointment of swella bravaman is
clearly highly controversial that was
his first question while he welcomed Mr
sunak has been the fast British Asian
prime minister he then went straight in
with a very short question saying was
the homosexual right to resign last week
and you knew where that was going
um Richie soon I tried to defend that
decision saying she recognized the error
of judgment I'm delighted to welcome her
back then
came back with what was another
difficult question was which was were
you advised by officials not to make
this reappointment now I have been told
by one source that the Prime Minister
was advised I have to say I have not got
that confirmed and it was only one prime
minister
neither did the Prime Minister and that
was a significant point he didn't ask
that question he dodged that question so
let's see how that one unfolds as a
urgent question potentially uh soon as
well and then he moved on his farmer to
the kind of Labor attack lines I think
we're going to see which is that Rishi
sunak is a very wealthy man he's out of
touch he brought up the issue of his
wife's non-dom status Rishi sunak is
aware that these questions are going to
come at him and and basically handled
them uh pretty well and when kirstarma
brought up the issue of this footage in
which Rishi sooner could talk about
moving money away from places in the
north back to wealthier constituencies
this is an attack line that labor will
use again and again and again at him he
sort of stood up and said I'm a prime
minister that will tell the truth so
Rishi sunak uh he said I told my party
hard trades when running you told them
fairy tales exactly so so what he's
saying is stop trying to paint me as
someone that doesn't tell the truth or
tries to be too political I am someone
that does tell hard truth this is my
character I am a politician of Integrity
thanks for finding the question I was
trying to scroll down so I just don't
know if I paid it just sounds very
helpful I couldn't quite if I was going
through my my notes
um so I think that that that that is a
clearer tagline from kirstan but the
final thing of course uh was the issue
of the general election and the question
of legitimu again will come up again and
again and again yeah Beth I know you've
got to go a busy day for you as
political editor Beth Rigby thank you
and don't worry I've got you I've got
the quotes here we work as a team don't
you worry about that um well earlier on
here on Sky News the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt announced that delay to the
financial statement it was due to take
place of course on Halloween but it's
now been pushed back into the 17th of
November here's what you have to say
earlier
our number one priority is economic
stability
and restoring confidence that the United
Kingdom is a country that pays its way
and for that reason the medium-term
fiscal plan is extremely important and I
want to confirm that it will demonstrate
debt falling over the medium term which
is very important for people to
understand
but it's also extremely important that
that statement is based on the most
accurate possible economic forecasts and
forecasts of public finances and for
that reason the Prime Minister and I
have decided that it is prudent to make
that statement on the 17th of November
when it will be upgraded to a full
Autumn statement
and I've discussed this uh last night
with the governor of the bank of England
he understands the reasons for doing
that and I'll continue to work very
closely with him
it's only 10 days since the governor of
the bank of England said that having the
government's plans first and then the
interest rate decision on the 3rd of
November was the correct order of events
by moving this until after the interest
rate decision aren't you just risking
more uncertainty more chaos more Market
turbulence well there has been a lot of
Market turbulence even in the last 48
hours and the question is how you deal
with that turbulence to make sure that
the very very important and very
difficult decisions that I and the Prime
Minister have to make are the right ones
decisions that stand the test of time
and do the right thing for people at
home who are worried about their
mortgages their jobs the cost of living
the bills and so on and for that reason
accuracy in the forecasts both around
public finances and economic growth is
very important and that's why this is
the right decision and a prudent
decision
foreign
decision our economics and data editor
Ed Conway is here with me now
um in talk when we're talking about
continuity and calming the markets how
this decision play into that Wish by the
new government well it's it's definitely
related to it because you know you've
got to remember this was brought forward
originally it was supposed to be I think
the 23rd it was originally going to be
like later on in December or next year
then it was brought forward by
quasiquoting the 23rd of November then
he brought it Forward again to the 31st
of October and all of the point there
was we were in a period of Market
turmoil the government needed to get out
there uh it's awesome show that it was
serious about about bringing down the
national debt that kind of is where this
starts and the idea was to do that
before the bank of England met remember
it's meeting next week on Thursday to
decide interest rates it's the first big
decision they've had obviously since all
of this turmoil the idea was to get in
there before that but since then markets
have calmed down quite a lot so the
rationale is basically markets are in a
better place and they haven't panicked
today in the in the wake of this
decision markets are in a better place
and also there is a kind of benign side
to it we've spent a lot of time recently
talking about black holes and what this
basically means in practice is the
government says it wants to get the
national debt falling at the moment it's
current plans see it Rising that's
worsened by the fact that interest rates
out there that it has to pay as well as
the stuff we have to pay are going up so
you have this bigger and bigger black
hole all the time well moving this back
actually might help on that front and
why because all of these decisions are
based on how big the obr the office
budget responsibility think the black
hole is and that's what we're going to
get on Monday and we would get a kind of
you know sense of how much they would do
in terms of austerity or whether it's
tax Rises to still haven't seen any of
those reports have we no exactly we're
gonna have to wait until the 17th of
November and we will have to wait for
that
um but here's the thing because the obr
reports and the size of the black hole
was if if it was going to come on one
day it would have been based on that
period when interest rates were really
high you know they've been really high
in the last few weeks now by delaying it
for a few weeks it means it can look at
the period when interest rates are quite
low the size of the black hole doesn't
looks so big so actually potentially
there's less work that the government
has to do in order to meet its Target to
get the national debt falling so it
could well be that this decision alone
could reduce the amount of cuts that
they feel are necessary uh in the next
few months and just quickly we've only
got 30 seconds left and the chancellor
said that this is being upgraded we're
going to get a full Autumn statement on
the November the 17th what does that
mean I think I mean it could be more
extensive so whereas before it was
literally just to update the markets on
what they were doing and to show they
were serious this time there could be
more in the way of policies whether it's
what happens with spending what happens
with taxes and also it's to try and
underline that it's a normality you know
we're back to normality that that thing
was going to be an emergency moment this
instead feels a lot more like we've had
Autumn statements before so it feels a
lot more like one of those that's the
idea anyway and right now the key thing
is markets do seem relatively calm
they're not panicking about this okay Ed
I know you're going to keep an eye on
those markets for us throughout the day
at Ed Conway our economics and data
editor the chancellor saying the best
way to make sure that these uh difficult
decisions uh stand the test of time is
to push that statement back that is
coming on the 17th of November thank you
a basketball reaction now to pmqs our
panel of Voters are standing by in
Dartford they've been watching uh what's
been happening let's go live to Sky's
Mackie Thompson who is in Dartford in
Kent uh testing opinions there this
afternoon Matthew
welcome to Dartford Golf Club Dartford
of course is the longest running
Bellwether constituency in the country
every election since 1964 the way
Dartford has voted the country has voted
so there's little better place in the
entire country to come to test the
waters of opinion we've assembled a
crack panel of local voters who are
going to give us their thoughts on on
that prime minister's questions
um Maggie I'm going to start with you
again in fact because you are the
resident conservative party member here
uh what did you think did he Inspire
confidence Mr Suna I stand by what I
said earlier
I feel
uplifted positive optimistic because
here we have a man who knows exactly
what he wants to do he's very calm the
way he dealt with all the questions that
were thrown at him he stayed very
positive and I sensed a forward momentum
he's sort of going to put Let the hand
break off and he will get things sorted
and I really trust this guy he's got
humility he's got an awareness and a
sensitivity and he cares about people
and that come came over when he stood at
that outside number 10 and gave his
speech does anyone else I mean Dennis
you share you said that you you thought
he was he inspired some confidence
inspired Comfort very good batsman
questions he I felt he had the facts it
is at his fingertips that he needed
without too much detail although he's
batted back questions and didn't fall
for any of the traps is he vulnerable to
some of that spin bowling from
kierstarma to to continue your analogy
on things like you know it's clear what
labor we're trying to do there to
portray him as the sort of out of touch
Rich prime minister whose wife of course
until recently had non-dom status is he
vulnerable to those attacks I don't
think I think so I mean
how can you how can you like ridicule a
guy because he's earned money who's come
into money you know doesn't doesn't
suffer his judgment around the country I
mean what better would you want than
someone who's rich and deserving and
earn money to actually run a country
does it make him out of touch for
example with with the lives of nurses
teachers for example I mean Seth what
are your thoughts on it's not
necessarily I mean we can't just dislike
because somebody has worked hard and
made made so much money
um I think he's not out of touch he's
someone who clearly from what we saw
earlier understands what needs to be
done and a good example is the is the
funnel scheme himself said I wouldn't
know what further was it looks I
probably started here in the UK and it
did go a long way to help a lot of
people here yeah definitely so I don't
particularly feel like because you are a
millionaire for which you've actually
worked hard for means you're out of
touch or you don't actually feel what a
nurse or the teacher or the white man
wouldn't wouldn't need a want and Pierce
Stormer for example I mean does he does
he Inspire any confidence in you I mean
a lot of people uh across the political
Spectrum have been demanding a general
elections would you like to see uh give
labor a turn or
it will be nice it would be nice to have
a general election but this guy has only
been there two days two days in the job
yeah um he has to have a chance yes yes
he needs to be given a chance he seems
to have the support from the last thing
we can do whatever the color in my my
opinion is have another have a general
election now or within the next year
because we've had so much
unstable government so much we need
stability for good or for bad and as as
the speech was going on we saw the pound
starting to rise and into the markets
which are King
that we need to we need that stability
and general election will just kill the
Country Connection would cost so much
money and we're trying to conserve money
and also we've had enough of Muddy
Waters turbulent times we need calm and
stability and Rishi tsuna presented that
yesterday we've got to give them a
chance the country has to give him a
chance now he's sincere he's got a very
strong family ethos from his growing up
his parents probably quite humble the
fact they they worked hard brought him
through University
and family values are very important and
I think that's very significant that he
has an appreciation he also demonstrates
humility
uh one of the lines that kyostarma used
there was
um you know same old conservatives
putting party before country in the
sense that you know he had given a job
to suela Braverman who was sacked six
days ago for leaking uh State not
leaking but but handling State
information in securely
the same old conservative party you're
playing for a team you're going to help
with your teammates to Buena aren't you
if you you know your teammates are going
to help you win if that's best for you
and that's best for your country
you're going to do that but that's not
wrong that's good for everybody as soon
as she knew she'd done wrong I think
what was the Contrition there I suppose
and if you want the difficulty we're
having here I mean
Integrity is very very important I mean
Superman left she was because she was in
Bridge she admitage was in Bridge of the
ministerial Court it is not I am in the
Peter mandelson he also left some back
in the days but he came probably two or
three years later not six days this is
too short and I'm thinking yes young
sunak you are doing well there was
positive vibes in the chamber earlier
but there are things they need to look
and look at very very careful I'm gonna
have to I'm going to have to injure I
mean we could talk about this all day
couldn't we it was fascinating to hear
all your thoughts thank you ever so much
uh guys back to you in the studio but
that's the thoughts of the country's
leading Bellwether constituency no
better place to take the temperature
yeah interesting stuff Matthew thank you
and thank you to your panel as well
you're watching Sky News coming up next
Kanye West dropped by companies like
Adidas over his anti-semitic remarks
we'll have the story for you
[Music]
I'm in the man Rasheed and I'm Skies
north of England correspondent telling
stories from this culturally Rich region
I call home
it's going to become very similar to
other places and lose its unique
qualities it's steeped in history
[Music]
if the Taliban found your family what
would happen I think they're just going
to straight away execute them there are
issues of racism in